yeah alright so I'm pretty happy with my
opening I think I'm quite a bit better
most likely either a much better or I'm
not not doing anything awesome I'm
feeling pretty good at the moment better
than I've felt the past two days at
least so looking forward to seeing how
the game plays out exactly I'm feeling
good right now I think for the round
there was a question about what what did
you eat for breakfast and so this
morning I chose to eat some Scottish
smoked salmon with a bagel and it was
just delicious and maybe that's
contributing to why I feel so happy
about everything right now hi everyone I
just wanted to share that generally you
three would give me a sufficient
compensation I think but I think in this
position if my coach a chef Nathanial I
was playing white he would surely play
Knight h4 so I thought just to honor him
with moving the game in my calculation I
think the position becomes balanced but
it's such a share position you can
always ponder things so I'll help
the excitement will not be just for my
saying this much so I've given up a
piece that looks interesting I think
we're both not prepared for this
I'm glad you started thinking you know
he was blitzing arrows before that but
yeah I think it's a game
anything can happen so we'll see